oui
[Musique]
c'est par moi aussi on ira où
bienvenue dans la zone libre de boulder
tu m'appelles ce tour hedman lequel de
vous et là rien de rudes
comment vous savez que je suis à votre
avis meira beagle tout ce que je sais
c'est qu'on a rêvé d'elle et qu'elle est
apparue elle nous a tous réunis et elle
veille sur nous en ces temps
d'incertitude
j'arpente les chemins de la révélation
je sais que tu sens sa présence il se
fait appeler l'homme noir le plus
souvent je ne vois que son loup merapi
gaël nous a dit qu'il y avait deux camps
le bien
et un gouffre sans fond d'où jaillissent
les ténèbres
promenons nous dans les bois pendant que
le loup n'y est pas bout dans le monde
avant il nous apprenait ne jamais revoir
leur époque est révolue
cette nouvelle montre des jours sombres
nous attend
des jours de morts et de terreur
[Applaudissements]
l'homme noir
harry plus puissant d'europe
bientôt il détruira tout ce qui se
dresse sur son chemin
aujourd'hui le monde est une page
blanche
elle est parmi nous
c'est à vous d'affronter ce fléau